hey glamour it's ivani and i'm here to
answer some questions
show you an eyeshadow look and show you
some of my fav beauty products
okay so now i'm going to be showing you
one of my really easy eyeshadow looks
that i like to do
with my palette when i just need a pop
of color on my eyes
so i've already primed my eyes but i'm
going to go in with inaudible noise
which is my white shadow
and i'm going to get some on my brush
tap
and apply that all over my eyelid i
am obsessed with the shadow
because it is so pigmented and i just
like
the one y shadow that i've used that
just stays
so now that i have the white shadow
applied i'm going to go in
with any color i have in here got a lot
of options
but specifically i'm going to go in with
mama's fave because it matches my shirt
and you're just going to get some on the
garage
and apply this to your eyelid at the
bottom
and i just pat it in and then i blend
afterward
and once you're done this is what it
looks like very quick very simple
[Applause]
now here are some products that i
literally cannot live without because
it's in my everyday routine
first is this moisturizer my face gets
so dry
around my eyelids just literally all
over and i could not find anything
that would cure this issue except this
this has helped me so much i cannot look
without this next is the beauty bakery
flower setting powder
this i did not know i needed until i
bought it i use it every single day
every time i need to use it
this is straight what i go for and if
anyone asks me what to use i will say
this
so if you didn't know i do have a
collection with morphe it's morphe x
vani greg and it's a whole collection of
stuff but i wanted to specifically
talk about my palette i made sure to put
every shade in there that i wanted to
see
in a palette that i could carry around
and i was able to do that and
most of the names on here are family and
friends and
it's just like having my family and
friends with me all the time because i
always have this with me
next is my well glow i use this almost
every single day
actually i do use it every single day
because i take pictures every single day
but other than that
i love to put this on when i go out and
take pictures because the sun hits it
and it's just
stunning next thing that i didn't know
that i needed until i got it
was the morphe 2 hide and peak concealer
this is my favorite concealer this
is my love i'm just kidding but i use
this
anytime i need to go for a concealer and
i have a lot of concealers laying around
and this is the one that i always go for
this is that one is amazing lastly
is my morphe x bonnie greg bronzer this
is in shade of hawaii i use this
so much so much contour
bronzing collarbones everywhere it has a
little bit of glow to it so it's really
amazing
[Music]
some beauty trends that i've been seeing
that are like really exciting right now
is that people are digging more into
using
colors like colored liners and like
bright neon colors and glitter and like
people are just like throwing it all
over their face and making it an amazing
look
and that is what's really exciting
because i love seeing that really keeps
me interested
and like watching a video or like
looking on instagram and i feel like
people just keep on adding to that and
just making it better so it just keeps
getting more exciting
there are so many people that are
inspiring me that i literally cannot
give you names
because i don't know but my for you page
and my instagram explore page is filled
with inspiration all the time that's why
i've been so motivated lately
one thing that i have on my bucket list
that i
am ready to complete is to give you guys
more scary makeup content i've been
working
on some ideas and i am excited for you
guys to see those
tips for tick tock are kind of hard just
because it depends on what content you
are posting
i post makeup and fashion so i always
want to like
bring something that maybe not everyone
has seen on your page something that
makes you stand out more when it comes
to posting trends
always try to add a little bit of my
twisted trends if i can and that's
usually what keeps
my page alive the process behind making
my
makeup videos like on tic tac youtube
instagram all that kind of stuff it's
not really as crazy as
you might think it is i start out with
an emotion that i am feeling
based off of what like makeup look that
i'm trying to go for if i'm going for a
regular
daily makeup look i don't really have an
emotion behind that it's more like what
am i wearing that day but when it comes
to me doing crazier
clown makeups and more characteristic
makeup looks
i really feel an emotion and then i
start to
build it all together i usually draw it
out and then i
plaster it on my face with my makeup
taking care of my mental health while
being on social media and my well-being
in general
is very hard and that's why i usually
take
breaks i will take maybe almost three
to five days off of just staying fully
off of my phone and just like
doing beauty stuff doing random makeup
stuff laying in bed
eating my favorite food just like get me
back in the right mindset so that i can
give the best content out to everyone
else
i don't necessarily hype myself up
before filming
but i do need somewhat some motivation
to get out of bed and film
because sometimes i just want to lay in
bed all day but
what helps like motivate me is when i'm
just you know scrolling through tick
tock seeing everyone else post videos
and i'm like
okay maybe i need to get out maybe i
need to film maybe i need to be active
on my gowns
you know it just really depends on the
day i don't
i don't really have anything that's
really exciting about me that no one
knows about because i am very public
with
my life i want everyone to know exactly
how i'm doing and exactly how i'm
feeling
i would say that my relationship with
beauty has changed a lot
since i've grown up basically i mean
i've gotten more into
taking care of my actual skin before
applying you know
makeup so actually doing skin care
because before i wasn't doing that i
wasn't thinking about it and now
that i am i am happy to be my favorite
beauty look that i have created
is all of them because they
all mean different things to me which
makes me for who i am and i just really
i can't really pick and choose between
them
thank you glamour for featuring me and
letting me show you what beauty means to
me and also thank you for letting me
show off my morphexilvani gray
collection
i hope you guys enjoyed until next time
bye